[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre los procesos para
destituir a donald trump es por ello que
agradecemos esta comunicación con rafael
cox alomar help es abogado
constitucionalista también profesor de
derecho de la universidad del distrito
de columbia washington dc recordemos que
hubo cinco muertes en una tarde de caos
cuando partidarios de trump tomaron
control del capitolio interrumpiendo la
sesión del congreso y forzando a los
congresistas a esconderse por horas
tenemos dos opciones aquí profesor otro
renuncia el día de hoy lo que parece
poco probable o se convertirá en el
primer presidente de enfrentar un
segundo impeachment
la mente la situación que es inminente
de que hay una votación en la cámara
federal muy posiblemente miércoles
mañana sobre la radicación de nuevos
artículos de residencia miento contra el
presidente tro y la otra alternativa es
que se invoque la vigésimo quinta
enmienda pero eso requiere la
participación principal del
vicepresidente page y una mayoría del
gabinete presidencial y eso tal parece
que no están las cartas en esta
coyuntura
si trump no sale hoy lo que parece poco
probable como lo destacó usted la cámara
desencadenará el proceso de impeachment
y trump enfrentaría entonces el cargo de
incitación a la insurrección debido a su
rol en este asalto al capitolio del 6 de
enero para usted es un cargo sólido
pero definitivamente la evidencia está
ante el mundo la evidencia es
contundente
sobre la tentativa de insurrección de la
autoridad del presidente el problema con
el residencia miento es que queda muy
poco tiempo para la juramentación del
presidente electo bailén y hay mucha
incertidumbre constitucional sobre si es
de forma retroactiva se le pudieran
causar a trump aún después de haber
dejado la casa blanca es decir no queda
claro si la constitución americana
establece porque no está no surge del
texto de la constitución que uno pueda
descalificar prospectivamente un
presidente de volver a aspirar a la
presidencia luego de que esta persona
sale de la casa blanca
bien si no me equivoco la probabilidad
de que el proceso tenga éxito es muy
poca los demócratas no tienen la mayoría
de los dos tercios que necesitan en el
senado y falta tiempo el senado está en
receso hasta el 19 de enero es decir en
la víspera del traspaso de los poderes
porque los demócratas insisten con el
impeachment
pero yo entiendo que ellos quieren que
se marque para la historia de que trump
ha sido el peor presidente de los eeuu
que quede con la mácula de haber sido el
único presidente de la historia que ha
sido sometido a artículos de residencia
miento no solamente una vez sino en dos
ocasiones
y la posibilidad de ves calificarlo de
cara al futuro me imagino que ellos van
a intentar esa vía aún después de la
salida de trump porque la constitución
establece que son dos los remedios que
provee el residencia miento la remoción
la destitución de la posición y al mismo
tiempo la descalificación para siempre
de esa persona de poder aspirar a volver
a ocupar posiciones de confianza
posiciones principales en cualquier tipo
de posición de honor en el gobierno
federal así que yo entiendo que ellos
van a perseguir esa vía yo van a buscar
esa vía
pero sobre esa vía se ciernen es seria
es serio cuestionamiento constitucional
profesor el proceso de impeachment
seguiría entonces su curso incluido
después del 20 de enero cuando va a ver
la transferencia de poder a biden es
esto correcto que se espera entonces
bueno es posible pero sobre eso no
existe precedente para encausar
a un presidente luego de que haya salido
de casablanca en 1864 se encausó a un
secretario de la guerra luego de haber
renunciado pero ese precedente no
necesariamente aplique al presidente de
trump y esos precedentes nunca han sido
scrum escudriñado por el tribunal
supremo a los estados unidos así que en
ese escenario con toda certeza eso
eventualmente iría camino al derecho al
tribunal supremo de eeuu para que se
exprese sobre la constitucionalidad de
una acción de esta naturaleza
muchas gracias profesor rafael cox
alomar por esta comunicación por su
análisis al abogado constitucionalista y
muchas gracias ustedes por su compañía
sigan con más en france 24
[Música]